so I won't steal any more time from our
speakers and we'll come back to be
there's a lot of things to discuss about
design and selection afterwards so I'll
turn the floor over to cosmo without
further ado thanks to get this to work
okay everyone can hear me everyone is
awake after the food coma so I want to
talk about issues of studying social
social contagion social influence causal
inference on networks and when I was
trying to come up with a title I
suggested this one to Jennifer and said
if it wasn't provocative enough I I
could I could dial it further out
hopefully this the fact that I ended it
with a question mark rather rather than
an exclamation mark is is going to give
a bit of a cue that I think there's some
hope but there's not going to be a lot
so let me start by by giving you the
summary first because this is when you
might actually remember what what I'm
saying rather than at the end and so
there are three big things I'd like you
to walk away with as things which we
should pretty much all agree with as far
as as studying social influence and
networks goes the first is that there's
no question social influence exists ok
so the we know that it happens we know
it happens for lots of things that's not
in dispute that's not the interesting
question and the second thing which
shouldn't be in dispute is that if
you're just going out and doing an
observational study in a social network
you are not generally going to identify
social influence effects and this is not
just because it's hard to identify
causal effects from observations there
are specific reasons why in networks
social influence is very hard to
identify and we'll go over that and if
you want to identify it the it's not
going to be done through mere technical
trickery or fancy regressions I'm taking
food out of my own students mouths by
saying this but it's not just going to
come from better stats we're going to
need either special assumptions are rich
I'm going to try and talk about what
that might look like now the things
which might help us are going to be
richer measurements I'm not going to say
very much about that because I I can't
really help you with that I'm that needs
actual science I'm going to talk a bit
about some ideas about network
clustering which might be a reason to
actually go out and identify communities
as opposed to just having nicer nicer
pictures of our hair balls there might
be some way forward through elaborating
mechanisms through which we think
influence might happen and there might
be ways of doing this through partial
identification or bounding effects even
if we can't point identify them and so
time permitting i'll talk about all of
those and if time really permits i might
say why even experiments are hard so you
know the first thing we should agree
with is that social influence exists and
it is important for a lot of things and
the the existence proof I'd like to use
is language the fact that we are all
speaking this dialect from from amex
cure corner of Eurasia spoken by a bunch
of of Germans conquered by Vikings
conquered by French people conquered by
the Dutch with a lot of Latin loanwords
none of this is happening because we all
somehow spontaneously decided that this
was a good way of communicating and so
this is all happening through social
influence and we know it happens on much
smaller scales my neighbors in
Pittsburgh speak funny they say things
like the car needs washed whereas my
brothers neighbors and Cambridge speak
funny they said things like the car
needs to be washed and again none of
this is happening because of the
influence of the different rivers we get
our drinking water from or something
even though if you r aggressed accent on
writ on water source you would get
excellent results this is happening
because of social influence so we know
this thing sort of thing happens it
happens all through pieces of culture it
happens for all sorts of important
things not just how do you talk about
cars but things like how do how do
organize an economy or how do you make a
basket all these sorts of important
things actually spread through social
influence they don't necessarily spread
through just copying there's a wonderful
book by an anthropologist named Dan
sperber about all the problems with
assuming people just copy each other and
just imitate each other and what are the
other ways in which people influence
each other but it's important and it
happens and and we need to understand it
and you know what happens when you have
this sort of social influence is going
to depend very strongly on the structure
of the network so matt has has worked on
this I'm going to show you a little toy
example because I was raised as a
physicist and that's how we think so
here is is our toy model of the
evolution of culture there every person
is a note and every person makes a
choice at every time point they choose
to either wear a red hat or a black hat
they choose to either vote for the red
hearty red party or the black party and
this is a network which was generated
from from a two-block model and you can
see the two blocks because they settled
down nicely and here initially I've just
colored everybody randomly by flipping a
coin and then they're going to follow
the the simplest possible process of
social influence I'm going to close my
eyes and I'm going to pick a random
person and that random person is going
to close their eyes and pick a random
neighbor and say I like the color of
their hat I like the color of that had
so much i'm going to copy that i'm going
to start wearing hats of that color
whatever had i'm currently wearing okay
so this is that if you if you've done
stat mech you know we call this the
voter model if not this is a obviously a
trivial horrible caricature of all sorts
of things as social influence so what
happens if you run this again here
initially I've just flipped a coin
independently for everybody so there
should be no association between which
block you're in and your choice but you
run this for 4 300 updates and and the
East has become red and so you know half
of
you know one community one block has by
chance tended to pick up you know the
red color and then because most of your
neighbors are in the same block when you
look around for somebody to copy that's
going to tend to persist and the other
block happens to have chosen the
opposite color and so you know if you go
and you run a logistic regression of of
your of your color choice on which block
you're in you know ignore the error bars
because they're wrong here but you start
out with basically nothing because we
chose it randomly and then you'll get an
effect going one way and you know you
get a logistic regression coefficient of
about one and a half from this one and
then it fluctuates for a while and then
in this particular run it actually
happened to switch back over so there
happened to be a spontaneous reversal of
the association between these two and
then we got tired of running this
eventually of course ever in this very
simple model everyone would settle down
on the same color for their hat and then
there would be no change in the future
but you could imagine all sorts of
things like adding a little bit of
spontaneous noise or the occasional
appearance of the new hat color and so
forth okay so if you're looking at
something like this all that's going on
here is this very simple process of
social influence but it's giving you
these weird large scale patterns which
say now all of a sudden there's a deep
there's a there's a strong association
between which part of the network you're
in and what color hat you wear this
choice you're making and if you are
living in this network and you didn't
understand this you would tell yourself
all sorts of stories about why it is
that Easterners really like red hats and
what the deep meaning of red for people
living in the eastern half of the
network and the importance of marking
themselves off from the people from the
black hats who live in the West and so
forth and you would tell some elaborate
story about what happened around time
step 502 lead to this reversal and so
you might tell yourself some story which
looks like this which is the
presidential vote for the u.s. in 1896
where you had you know one part of the
country which was a which was which
voted for the Republicans and and then
you had the south and the Mountain West
which voted for the
pets and you know bye-bye 2004 of course
it looks like this and so everything has
flipped and you can go you know go down
to the library and you will find shelves
and shelves and shelves of books
explaining the deep meaning of this
transformation and I don't mean to say
that they're all wrong and this is all
just some random copying process in a
bias network but unless we have a good
understanding of what that sort of thing
can produce an we don't know that there
whether we don't know how much of what
we've seen in something like this is
just a social influence and diffusion on
the network and how much of this is
actually something being driven by
people who live in the northeast have
different interests and values and
that's why they chose a certain way
maybe they vote a certain way because
they just don't like to disagree with
their neighbors okay so social influence
exists it matters the problem which
makes this complicated is that homophily
also exists in it matters and so now
when we go out and we decide who were
friends with that's not usually handed
to us by the great randomizer in the sky
it's not even usually assigned to us by
by some thai some experimenter unless we
live in some totalitarian society like
the air force academy or dartmouth where
you do have some random assignment of
friends so you know under under
conditions of totalitarianism you can
have randomized networks but you know
otherwise we make choices they're not
totally free we might end up being
friends with people because there's no
one else for us to be friends with
because all the cool kids have rejected
us but we will still have some sort of
home awfully some sort of selection of
the friendship ties and those ties so
those ties are going to depend on our
attributes they'll depend on things like
what caste were we born into or you know
how you know you know do we do we like
drinking beer or would we rather go to
the gym you know do we prefer exercising
over beer and these sorts of attributes
are going to have lots of impact on
behaviors you know if you to know some
thing about what kind of person I am
you're going to be able to say things
about about my behavior about my health
even about what sort of politics i'm
going to like so we've got to two things
going on one is that there's no other
social influence so if i can tell you
some you know because of social
influence if I know what your neighbors
are doing I can say something about what
you're going to do and we also know that
their selection of ties so I can look at
your hoo-hoo unit who your neighbors are
and that's going to tell me something
about what kind of person you are and so
then of course you're going to do
similar things because you're similar
sorts of people so I have two very
different mechanisms which both lead to
correlated behavior among people who are
close to each other in a social network
it could be influenced or it could be
selection both of them are going to mean
that i'm going to unpredictable from
what my neighbors do and it would be
nice to be able to tease these apart and
as scientists we'd like to we just like
to understand this as people who have to
go out and do things in the world we
would like to be able to know which
interventions are going to be effective
if you know if kids really in high
school really do learn to smoke from
each other and there really is peer
pressure for smoking then you know
separating the separating the the good
kids from from the smokers might
actually achieve something or you might
want to target the kids who are sitting
out back behind the gym and convince
them that they really don't want to
smoke because if you can get some of
those as influential as it's going to
have this impact on the others if on the
other hand the reason all the the
smokers hang out together is that
they're there they're the ones who are
already feeling alienated from high
school and that's why they want to do
that sort of thing and you know they'd
be smoked they'd be just as likely to
smoke anyway even if they didn't have
other smoking friends to hang out with
then that sort of intervention is not
going to be very useful you need to
target people individually and again
this isn't just for things like can you
keep kids from smoking it would it's
also for things like can you get people
to go out to vote
or can you get people to go out and buy
a totally superfluous electronic gadget
because their friends are buying it and
so on and so forth okay so so these are
things which are would have a lot of
consequences if we can tease these two
things apart and this is a causal
inference question it's not just a
regression question it's not just a
conditional probability question we
really do want to know what happens if
we take if we take somebody and
influence them if we manipulate them
what's going to happen to their friends
and so you know there how could we begin
to do this from observational data
there's basically three main ways you
can get causal identification the first
one which we pound into their heads in
baby stats is you could do controls so
you could say look I'm going to find the
right set of control variables I'm going
to find the right set of covariance and
I'm going to condition on them so you
know with a modern techniques you can
actually explain what it means to have
the right set of control variables you
want to find variables that block the
indirect pathways from the cause to the
effect and you don't want to block the
direct pathways you don't want to
condition on the stuff which leads from
the cause to the effect and you also
don't want a condition on things which
create independent indirect pathways
which wouldn't ordinarily be there so
this is what Judea pearl in a perhaps
unfortunate phrase called the backdoor
criteria you want to close all of the
backdoor paths from the cost of the
effect the second thing you can do
especially if you're an economist is you
look for an instrument and so you could
say look I'm going to find something
some some source of variation in the
cause which is just totally independent
of everything else and I'm going to see
how that source of variation in the car
if that that variation in the cause is
associated with the effect the only way
that can happen is if I'm wiggling the
cause somehow and the cause has to then
channel it to the effect and so so then
I've got a pretty convincing case and
the third thing you can do is you can
try and find some sort of mechanism you
can say look I know I have some
understanding of how this cause would
really do things to the effect variable
I'm interested in and I
can measure each step along that chain
and so then I can actually identify the
causal effects even if I can't control
for everything even if i don't have
independent variation of the cause so
this is what pro calls the front door
criterium so let me just explain a you
know this control idea this is a set of
pictures we probably ought to to inflict
in baby stats but for some reason we
don't so you know I I have a student
Joey Joey wants to go to graduate school
Joey wants to know if studying for the
GRE is actually going to get him into a
better program so Joey goes out and
collects data and Joey sees that there
is indeed a correlation between his
students GRE scores and the rank of the
graduate program they get into and
before Joey can conclude anything about
how much would improving his GRE score
do for him he really ought to control
for some things and so you know one of
the things you have to control for is
that students who spend more time
studying as undergrads are probably
going to also therefore score higher on
the GRE but they're going to get into a
better graduate program for independent
reasons like they'll have better grades
and they'll have nicer letters from
their teachers and so forth so you know
in this case we have a common cause of
the two variables we ought to control
for the common cause right so far so
good the problem is when we control for
common effects so Joey has a friend
Irene and Irene would like to go off to
Hollywood and become an actress and
Irene being a CMU student goes out and
collects data before she takes this
plunge and so she goes and she looks at
you know she wants to know you know for
instance when she looks at at actors is
there some association between their
looks and they're acting ability because
she's an econ stat student at CMU she
knows that people respond to incentives
and so she thinks that probably uh
actors who are better looking don't
practice as much and so there should be
a negative association between looks and
acting ability and so she goes out and
she collects data where she looks at
which she she gets data on lots of
actors
and has people rate their looks online
and she has people look at clips at them
of them and rate how good an actor they
are but she doesn't have unlimited time
so she just takes the thousand top
actors according to their IMDb entries
so she selects actors who are successful
she only looks at actors who are above
some some threshold level of success and
then she's going to find that negative
relationship even if they're totally
independent she's going to be controlled
she's controlling or selecting on a
common effect and that creates a
conditional association between those
two between the two very the two parent
variables so you know this is a here
it's a pure selection effect we get the
same thing if you were controlling for
this if you were dressed acting ability
on looks controlling for success as an
actor you would get the same sort of
effect so you know when you control for
a common effect you are creating an
indirect pathway which links these two
things if you are just a medium
successful actor there's going to be a
negative association between your looks
and your acting ability because they're
probably not they're much better not
outstandingly successful in either one
and if you're just a median successful
actor so this is what we want to avoid
we want to find the causal effect the
common causes and control for them but
we want to avoid conditioning or
selecting on common effects and now it's
totally trivial to understand why we
can't identify social influence from
observations this is the this is the
causal diagram we r we want to look at
irene's behavior tomorrow and we want to
know is it caused by joeys behavior
today this is what we would like to
identify there's only going to be that
that causal link if Irene and Joey are
friends why would they be friends well
that's going to depend on their latent
traits okay they're going they're going
to have various traits which on which
their home office maybe these are things
like cast maybe there are other
attributes you know maybe they're things
like do they like to go to the bar every
day for at happy hour or do they meet
because they
go to the gym because they're both
training for triathlons all sorts of
things are going like this are going to
go into are they friends but I look at
Joey's behavior today and that tells me
something about what kind of person Joey
is it tells me something about their
traits knowing the Joey and Irene are
friends I can deduce something about
Irene straights and then of course i can
predict something about Irene's behavior
tomorrow ok so I'm selecting the people
i regress on I select them so that they
are in fact related to to to each other
so that Joey and Irene are similar and
then even if those edges those arrows
those causal pathways aren't there at
all even if there's no social influence
whatsoever I'm going to have
predictability from Joey's behavior
today to Irene's behavior tomorrow so
there's the this is this is the pro this
is a problem now you can make the same
argument with with all the algebraic
symbols and some theorems I'm not going
to give us that and partly in the
interest of time partly because it
doesn't really add anything to this end
to the essentials the real issue is that
is that we have this endogenous baked in
selection bias the network ties are
endogenous they are formed as part of
the same process which generates the
behaviors were interested in and that
means that who is a the you know which
people are available as regressors as
predictors for my behavior for egos
behavior is informative about what kind
of person ego is and so there's
endogenous selection bias and it's just
not going to go away there there's
basically nothing you can stick into
that that graphical model that path
diagram where you can condition on it
that's going to block that indirect
backdoor pathway now people don't like
this conclusion so they're a bunch of
things that they would like to you see a
claim would would get rid of it one is
controlling for prior history that
doesn't work one is looking at changing
network ties so seeing whether P you
know seeing these things check alter
wooden toys form and disappear that
doesn't work one is propensity score
matching because who doesn't love a good
propensity score that unfortunately
doesn't work one would
is a lot clever and was a lot harder to
understand why it doesn't work is ace
asymmetric ties where you have a
directed graph and the ties are
asymmetric that also doesn't work so how
am i doing on time not okay very briefly
the idea of with conditioning on history
is this I'm going to look at not just
you know behavior today and tomorrow for
joy and Irene I'm also going to look at
joeys behavior yesterday and Irene's
behavior yesterday and I'm going to
throw those in as control variables okay
so this is an this is an obvious sort of
thing but again as soon as you draw the
diagram it's obvious why it doesn't work
because it doesn't walk that back door
pathway where we look at Joe what Joey
did today we learn something about Joey
and then we learned something about
Irene and I change mat as I read hold
that thought um so you know that diagram
was a bit of a mess you know obviously
I've got all these extra arrows going
alone if I wanted to allow the social
network tie between them to fluctuate it
looks more and more like a plate of
spaghetti but you can actually trace
everything through and even if you
include lag values of behavior or lag
values of the social tie it doesn't
eliminate the confounding it doesn't
give you identification and it can
actually make the identification worse
the bias worse and the reason is that
these extra time points you're including
also carry information about the latent
attributes if those are redundant if
these are all redundant and giving us
similar information about the attributes
then we're reducing the bias and maybe
asymptotically you would reduce it to
zero if you had infinite histories but
if they're giving us non redundant
information then we can actually
increase the confounding and in general
it's got you know I won't say whether
it's going to go one way or the other
it's just not going to eliminate the
problem propensity scores are a cute
trick we look at some covariance we
figure out what's the probability
that there's a tie between Irene and
Joey and then whether there's actually a
ties only depends on the propensity
score it's in the the attributes are
irrelevant but this is true whether it
blocks the indirect pathways or not okay
so this is true whether we've got
identification or not and so there's
some very cute papers where people take
real experiments and say what
conclusions would you reach if you just
did propensity score matching on
observational variables in these
situations where we know the
experimental truth and you can conclude
things like calling people up and
reading them a message saying it's very
important to wear your seat belt all the
time causes them to go vote and and I
will leave you to ponder why you would
conclude that if you just did match
controls or you can you can track down
the paper and spoil it for yourself so
the asymmetry one is very clever and you
know it okay we're worth a little
thought so I look at edges which aren't
reciprocated and so this is the this
high school tragedy where you go to
Irene and Irene says Joe is your friend
and Joey pretends not to know who I
Rena's and so you do a regression of
Irene on Joey and you get one answer and
you do a regression of Joey on Irene and
you get a different answer and this
could be due to influence you know if
people pay more attention to those
they're going to claim or our friends
then that would be fine but you can also
get it without influence so we came up
with this very complicated story where
there's some awfully but there's also a
preference for some values of the latent
trait and then seeing that the edges
unreciprocated tells you that you know
Irene has a less desirable value of the
latent trait Russ Lions had realized
that it all you need is a non-uniform
distribution of the latent trait and
asymmetry then it's just telling you the
person reciprocated the person who's
sending the tide but not receiving it is
in a low density part of the space and
in boat either case since you're
learning something about the latent
variables you can predict something
about their behavior so this is really
just Bayes rule symmetric prior
antisymmetric data you
an antisymmetric posterior nothing to it
you could hope that there are parametric
models we don't know of any we bash
their heads against the linear Gaussian
case for four months it doesn't seem to
work so what about instruments this is
our wounds question so we want to find
some variable which is going to predict
what Joey does which is going to affect
what joy does and see if we can use that
to predict Irene right and it the
important thing is that the instrument
can only affect Joey if the instrument
has any other pathway through which it
tells us about Irene then it done it's
not a not a good instrument so we need
to block all the other pathways and so
what people like to suggest is using a
friend of a friend so we introduce Carl
who is a friend of Joey but not of Irene
and zero so you want to look at this
nice blue pathway where you look at Carl
what Carl did and then use that to
predict Joey and then you use Joey to
predict Irene and if that that should
only happen if there is in fact social
influence but you know knowing something
about Carl and the fact that Carl and
Joey are friends tells you something
about Joey and knowing something about
Joey and the fact that Joey and I read
our friends tells you something about
Irene so you have this unblocked
backdoor pathway and it's not a valid
instrument okay now I don't want to say
there are no valid instruments again is
if you're running a totalitarian
enterprise like Facebook you could
introduce lots of instruments but you
know friends of friends certainly aren't
one so this is all the negative stuff so
we can identify things it would be
wonderful we know it exists we can
identify it from observation and you
know this isn't an issue of the data
being too small you can have your data
be as large as you like sitting on on as
many distributed machines as you like
and it's not going to help I will so I
was going to say something about
measurement I don't have time to say
something about measurement I will say
something about clustering because this
has come up a lot the fundamental
problem here is that we have this X
variable these latent attributes and
they're legging we can't
measure them so we would it would be
nice if we could somehow get away from
that and somehow see what they are we're
not going to be able to really measure
them properly and in a real measurement
sense but maybe we can we can proxy them
so if you believe that the network forms
through him awfully then you're going to
tend to resemble your neighbors and this
is going to be very pronounced if you
have lots of neighbors in common like if
there are lots of triangles and so those
people are also going to have tend to
have lots of neighbors in common with
you and so forth so if you believe in
layton homophily your network should
break up into modules or communities and
so you should tell you you should then
be able to reverse that you should say
well look I found my clusters and I
don't know what this X variable is but I
know that somehow it's it's showing up
in these communities so you know if if
you can convince yourself that the
estimated communities were a sufficient
statistic 4x4 the light and attributes
then you would just throw those in as
control variables in your regression and
you'd be done so we currently have no
idea when that holds we don't know how
to make this work for a block model
which isn't pure homophily we don't know
what would happen if the right block
model was not pure homophily but you
used pure homophily anyway whether it
might not be bias amplifying and and so
on and so forth so I have a student
who's working on this now and hopefully
she will have some results by spring
when she when she has to leave and go up
and become a real girl but you know this
is this is I think a promising approach
where we try and use the rest of the
graph to figure out at least a proxy for
the for the latent attribute which goes
beyond this these dyads were looking at
and it might actually give us a reason
to do community discovery as opposed to
just having pictures and theorems
mechanisms mechanisms would be nice it's
too hard to measure them and I think I'm
out of time am I not right so I will
just leave this up with for this idea of
partial identification
there may be situations where even if we
can point to identify things we could
put non-trivial bounds on it and there
now some papers which do this under
extremely strong assumptions this again
seems like a promising approach but we
don't have but it's it's all very new
and the assumptions are currently too
strong for for industrial use okay
thanks very much for your attention
sorry for running over